all right sit down we got a big show
[Applause]
okay yeah okay all right get the [ __ ] up
I'll get it
jeezum I'm glad you're keeping your chin
up in the depressed crowd huh well not
such a good week for the President on
the other hand man he lost lost his one
black friend yes if you have spent your
life as an American refusing to know who
morosa is well now your [ __ ] out of luck
because she's got a book to sell ad it's
about her time in the White House where
she was there for 18 months I believe
her official title was assistant
secretary for throwing shade oh boy is
she she has a lot to say about Donald
Trump Verity he said she said she said
boy he is a racist and he suffers of
dementia he said she's crazed and crying
and a low-life at a dog and Putin said I
can't believe I have to collude with
these people
you know let's not forget that Omarosa
did defend Trump a million times lied
for him after the election she said all
his detractors would have to bow down
before Donald Trump I don't care she's
our [ __ ] nap I'll take anything I can
get gladly but really this is where we
are this is where we are where the
reality show people are now the reality
and you know what you can't turn away
it's like watching earthworms made her a
hobo jack off it in the alley I don't
want to look at it but and we have to
hear it Marissa has tapes could you hear
the one Oh God did you're the one where
she's playing where she's talking to
Trump after she got fired and telling
him about to play that tape General
Kelly came to me and said that you guys
wanted me to leave
aside from everything else what a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] he
I didn't know it they they run a big
operation here boy I've ever ever find
this President of the United States guy
gonna find out what he and so vain she
says in the book that he immediately put
in when he could be in president a
tanning bed that he uses everyday Oh big
mix-up one morning a Rudy Guiliani was
getting into his coffin Trump was
getting out of the tanning bed and
luckily Maloney had just come out of her
sensory deprivation tank so she oh yeah
that's it Melania in the book I'm Rosa
is a Melania plans to divorce him as
soon as the term is over and she said
she's taking the kid and Trump said we
have a kid
Joseph says he drinks eight diet cokes a
day which cause dementia which i think
is probably true but diet coke come on
it's working he does have the body of a
Greek god I'm sorry he has the body of a
Greek diner here's my favorite she says
Obama Rosa says she what's in a black
church and she got up to do so but he
grabs her arm and says you can't leave
me here with these people you know
Christian oh yes he's got such a deft
touch with race this president does he
Aretha Franklin passed away I'm sure you
heard and of course this guy says yeah
she works for me she worked me a
complete lie this guy cannot say rest in
peace without lying Trump said he was
going to tweet his favorite Aretha song
respect but he couldn't remember how to
spell it
but there's a couple of couple of
actually important things going on -
Russian supersonic nuclear bombers did a
flyby right over Alaska
of course Republicans demanded an
investigation into the radar that
detected them they were they were so
close
Sarah Palin said she could see them from
her meth lab I just have to bring up
this story again cuz it's in news
remember the Baker in Colorado who would
refuse to make a wedding cake for the
gay couple went all the way the Supreme
Court right now he's back in court
because he wouldn't bake a cake for a
couple celebrating or somebody
celebrating Trent gender transition I
got a couple of questions one is there
only one bakery in Colorado also I see a
big business opportunity here I'm gonna
move to Grand Junction Colorado and open
a store called bang whoever you want
cakes